( intro music )
( applause )
Don George: I'm really excited
about this conversation.
I'm just going to
jump right into it.
You've written about so
many subjects, 23 books.
As far as I know, you've
never written about elephants,
so, I wanted to ask you
first of all,
what was the inspiration
for Leaving Time?
Jodi Picoult: Well, it was...
it had nothing to do
with elephants at
first actually. ( laughter )
So, I have three kids,
and my youngest is a daughter
named Sammy.
And she was getting ready
to go off to college.
And her brothers had
already left,
so, I was becoming
an empty nester.
And it upset me more than
I thought it was going to.
I was really thinking about
what it would be like
to be left behind.
And somewhere in the middle
of all that thought,
I read an article, probably
in the National Geographic
magazine,
that said that in the elephant
kingdom in the wild,
a mother and
daughter elephant,
stay together
their whole lives,
until one of them dies.
And I read that fact
and I thought,
'well why don't we do
it that way?'
I mean, it's much more humane,
you know. ( laughter )
And it kind of got me
thinking and...
and I began to do a little
background research
on elephants.
And in particular,
how their minds work.
A lot of people love
elephants, or you know,
collect elephants,
but don't necessarily realize
the cognitive abilities
that elephants have.
They can feel grief
and pain and loss
and they have
incredible memories.
All of those things are
part of the elephant brain
and the more I learned
about that,
the more I realize this was
the perfect metaphor
for the book
and that I had a profession
for one of the main characters
in the book.
Oh. Part of the challenge
of the book
is that you are writing
in different voices.
You are writing
in the voice of a scientist.
Was it difficult as a writer
to switch your brain
to do that?
No, this book
is the story of...
this woman, Alice Metcalf,
who studies elephant grief
and cognition,
and she runs a sanctuary
with her husband and one night
there's a horrible tragedy
at the sanctuary.
And a caregiver is trampled
by an elephant.
And the same night,
Alice disappears off
the face of the earth.
And the only...
the only person
who is a witness
is her three-year old
daughter, Jenna.
The problem is Jenna
can remember none of it.
And um... Jenna then begins
the book ten years later,
believing that
her mother never
would have left her willingly
and that
she is going to find
this woman.
And she enlists
the help of a failed
psychic named Serenity,
and an alcoholic detective
named Virgil.
And the three of them are
somehow going to find
her mother.
But you also get to hear
from Alice,
and the way you get to hear
from her
is the way Jenna
gets to hear from her.
By pouring over her research
entries and her journals,
and that's what Jenna's
done for the past 10 years,
is try to find her mother
literally between the lines
of what she's left behind.
Right. One of the things
that impressed me
so much about the book
was the beautiful, detailed
descriptions of elephant
behavior and just elephants.
And so you must have done a lot
of research for that,
and I'm wondering how
you went about doing
- that research.
- Yeah.
For this book, I knew that
I needed to see both elephants
in captivity and
elephants in the wild.
Because the main character
in the book
whose name is Alice Metcalf,
who is actually missing
for most of the book.
She drives the book
as her daughter Jenna
tries to find her.
Alice is an elephant
researcher
who studies grief and
cognition in elephants.
And she studies them
in the wild in Botswana
and then she runs sanctuary
with her husband
in New England.
So, I began by doing research
at a place called
The Elephant Sanctuary, which
is in Hohenwald, Tennessee.
The elephants
who come to live there
are elephants
who have been in circuses
and zoos their entire life.
And in many cases
have been very
horribly abused.
Coming to the sanctuary
means that they have
hit the jackpot
of retirement homes.
So, I got to see
how a sanctuary runs,
which was really important
for the book,
because a lot of the action
takes place in the sanctuary.
But I also needed to know
what Alice's research
was about.
And so I went to Botswana
and I worked with
an elephant researcher
who studies the migration of
elephants in the Tuli Block.
And, you know,
I got to observe some
incredible behaviors
of elephants
in their natural habitat,
which were phenomenal.
Everything that you read
in the book is something that
either I experienced
or that I was told by someone
at the sanctuary
or by this researcher,
so every story in there
is true.
Wow. How long were you
at each place?
I was in... at the elephant
sanctuary for just
a smattering of days.
It was couple of days,
but it's, you know,
it's 2700 acres,
most of which I wouldn't be
able to access by foot,
because I'm not an elephant.
( laughter )
And something that
a lot of people don't realize
is that elephants
in captivity often die of
foot problems,
because they've been standing
on concrete for so long
and if you think about it
in the wild
an elephant gets to walk
on top of different terrain.
So, for example, there was
an elephant at the sanctuary
that had such severe cracks
in her feet, that Teva...
you know the Teva company
that makes sandals?
They made these giant Tevas
for her
and she wore these
giant Tevas...
- Wow.
- around for a while. Yeah.
And then when I was in Botswana,
I was there for about a week.
It was fantastic because
you get up every morning
and you would
basically go on safari.
And I got to see this
fantastic matriarch.
The matriarch is the female
head of the herd,
who runs the herd.
She is usually
the biggest elephant,
and the one who has
the most collective knowledge,
often the oldest elephant.
And she was leading her herd
up this little incline
and sliding down on her butt,
over and over, like it was
a little playground slide,
and it was so much fun
to watch this
whole herd just keep doing it.
( laughter )
And then we came across
two young males,
they had this giant dung ball
which was kind of gross,
but they were kicking it back
and forth like it was soccer,
just back and forth,
it was totally play,
there was no other reason
for it.
You know, so it was really fun
to be able to see
behaviors like that.
- That's really, really great.
- Yeah.
Actually, so one of the
behaviors that fascinated me
because it is
so interesting is,
elephants grieving.
There is a lot of
elephant grieving in the book,
because Alice Metcalf
who is this missing mom...
that her daughter, Jenna is
trying find
throughout the book,
she studied elephant grief
and that was what really
amazed me the most
and people say,
"What's the coolest thing
you learnt about elephants?"
And it's that
they do have this depth of
understanding for loss
that I would not
have been able
prior to this, to attribute
to an animal.
Elephants that come across
the bones of another elephant
will get very somber,
their ears droop,
their tails droop, they have a
complete behavioral change.
And what's really interesting
is that
they don't act this way around
any other bones,
it's just the bones of
elephants.
They have been known and
very often return to the site
where an elephant has died
for years afterward,
as if they are paying
respects,
like they are going
to the grave site.
And again,
when they get there,
they get very quiet,
somber, reverential,
they stay for a few hours,
and then they move on.
They've been known to break
into research facilities
in the middle of the night,
and steal a bone
that a researcher is
working with,
and bring it back to the site
of that
- elephant's death.
- Wow.
And at The Elephant
Sanctuary in Tennessee,
there's this great story about
an elephant named Sissy.
Sissy survived the 1981 floods
in Gainesville...
by basically being submerged
for 24 hours
with just her trunk up,
like a little periscope.
- Wow.
- So, she was really
traumatized by the time
she came to the sanctuary
and it took her very long time
to bond with other elephants,
which they let happen
naturally,
which of course is one of the
issues with the zoos
because you know,
you can't just
stick to elephants together
and expect them to be friends.
So, she instead of bonding
with an elephant
began to carry around a tire,
like everywhere she went.
It was like
a security blanket,
like a little pacifier.
And for years,
she carried this tire around,
and then finally she bonded
with an elephant named Tina.
For years,
they were inseparable,
and then one day Tina got ill,
and she died.
When she died,
Sissy stayed with her
the whole time she was dying,
stayed by her grave
for a day after she died,
and then very carefully,
they watched her
take that tire,
and lay it on the grave,
kinda like we place a wreath.
And she left it there
for her friend.
As if she knew that
her friend needed it more now.
- Wow.
- Right? I know.
( laughter )
Amazing.
- That's really amazing.
- Yeah.
Maybe,
we should watch the clip
- on the elephant behavior.
- Oh yeah.
We have an amazing, wonderful
clip about elephant behavior
that we would like to share
with you all tonight.
Joyce Poole (VO):
This is a large adult male
named Stoney, and
he's doing what we call
tusk-ground
or tusking the ground.
Um, it's... look at him,
he is so silly,
look how he is right down
on the ground,
most of the males do this,
um, when they're
threatening another male,
it's kind of a way of saying,
"this is what I am
going to do with you
if I get hold of you."
Now, he is just looking at me.
And, he's now starting
to shake his head,
and doing
what I call a "head waggle".
Now,
that's an invitation to play.
This is just really cute
video of two young elephants,
two juveniles,
doing what we call
"play social rub".
They are lying on the ground
and just wiggling against
each other.
Elephants love to do this.
Especially kind of
in the late afternoon
when they had a lot to eat,
and they are feeling good.
This was filmed
in the evening.
It was about
an 11-year-old female
and two infant calves
that she was looking after.
And she was so cute with them.
She just laid down in this
sort of dust wallow here
and allowed them
to clamber all over her.
Look, watch this
balancing act here where he,
he tries to step on her,
on her trunk,
but it is little bit
too wiggly,
so then he decides,
okay, he'll just step
right on her face instead.
( laughter )
She doesn't mind.
- Isn't that great?
- It's wonderful.
It is so cool.
And poaching, we haven't
really touched on it yet,
that's the sad thing
about elephants
that when you fall in love
with them,
then you begin to realize
that they are being killed
at a rate of
38,000 elephants a year.
And by that estimate,
they'll be gone in the wild
in Africa in ten years.
And I don't know about you,
but I want my grandkids
be able to see elephants,
you know, so um...
it became very important
for me
to learn about poaching,
which I really didn't know
much about
and to...
to figure out
why it's important
for us in this country,
where we don't have elephants,
to really support
the initiatives to take care
of elephants that
are being threatened.
We know that poaching is more
than just a wildlife concern,
it's a humanitarian concern.
They've linked the money
from poaching
to Joseph Kony's Lord's
Resistance Army.
We know that Al-Shabaab
poaches one to three tons
of ivory every month
in Somalia, raising
$500,000 a month.
That goes a really long way
in Somalia
and Al-Shabaab has ties
to Al-Qaeda
and that's why it matters
- in this country.
- Wow!
Without you or someone like
you writing about this,
there is a small fraction
of people
in the world
who would be aware of it,
and especially
in the United States.
But everywhere that
your books are being sold
I just kinda felt like saying
on behalf of the planet,
- thank you for that.
- Wow, that's cool.
- I'll take that.
- No, I mean...
It's really, you know what,
there are...
( applause )
there are lot of reasons that
people become writers.
I'm really, really fortunate
because I go to my office
every day and I have the...
the opportunity
to entertain everyone.
But I also have this potential
- to educate a little.
- Yeah.
And I think if you can
leave the world
a better place
in some small way,
that's really important.
Yeah.
Hopefully, that's what
my books could do.
They could teach you
something you didn't know
and maybe open
your mind up a little
in a direction that
you didn't think
you were going to have to go.
Yeah, absolutely. It's...
- it's wonderful.
- Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
So, I was thinking as a writer
reading this, it's...
a fascinating journey
for you because
on the one hand you get
to become a scientist,
you get to become a psychic...
( laughter )
you get to become a detective.
Do you feel enriched and...
do you feel exhausted,
do you feel enriched,
do you...
because you're becoming
all these different people
in the course of
writing your book.
- How does that affect you?
- I actually feel lucky.
- Yeah.
- I feel really lucky
because I get to go to work
and I'm someone different
every day.
I do not feel as if I have
created Serenity or Virgil
or Alice or Jenna.
I feel like they are
speaking through me.
And I hear them. I hear them
very clearly in my head,
they talk to me,
they sometimes
wake me up at night
because they are
annoying and...
and honestly you know, they...
I've long said,
"my joke is that writing is
successful schizophrenia.
I get paid to hear voices."
- Right?
- There you go.
You know, but that's real,
I hear their voices.
I feel as if you guys are,
you know,
you can't see the movie,
you can't hear the movie,
so it's my job to tell you
what's being said.
When I am... I know I am
close to finishing a draft,
I can already hear
other people whispering like
- "ready".
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Really? Wow.
- Oh.
I'm sure there are people
in the audience
who have questions
that they brought with them
tonight and...
Right, so, there's
only one rule,
which is if you give away
the ending of any of my books,
- I'm going to kill you.
- Right.
So, right, keep that in mind.
Yes.
You don't want to do that.
- Don't do that.
- That's really,
There was a question
right there.
- Woman: Hi.
- Hi.
What is...
what was the hardest
and easiest part
of getting started
as a writer
with your very first book?
The easiest part about
getting to be a writer,
honestly was, um,
having the great good fortune
and the grades to get
into Princeton.
Because at the time
in the 80s,
there were not many
undergraduate
undergraduate creative
writing programs,
there were lot of
graduate schools,
but not undergrad.
And I had the opportunity
to work with
living breathing writers,
in particular one who really
shepherded me
into becoming
my own best editor
which I think is the most
essential tool for a writer.
I actually spent
a two-year period,
and this is the hardest part,
trying to find an agent.
I had over 100
rejections from agents.
A lot of people would
write me, and they are like,
"Yeah, you know, I just
got back my third rejection,
I don't know
if I could do this,"
and I'd just go, "yeah, okay,
whatever."
( laughter )
You know,
that is the hardest part,
honestly, of being a writer.
I think, believing
in yourself enough
that somebody eventually
takes the second look.
One person has to
really fall for it.
You know and
that kind of makes
the odds feel
a little bit better.
Let's come down
to the front please.
So, I have a question about
My Sister's Keeper .
How do I know that was
coming? Yeah.
It was the first book I read
and it totally got me
hooked on you.
But when I was
so excited for the movie,
after seeing it,
I wondered what your
opinion was on the change.
( laughter )
- That was so tactfully said.
- That was tactful.
( laughter )
So, here's the thing about...
about selling books for...
into movies, um,
what most of you
don't realize is
that the writer does not
have any say
over what happens.
There are exceptions,
but in the vast
majority of cases,
you sell your property
to a studio and then they
do whatever they want to do.
And you are not asked for any,
you know, any contributions
whatsoever.
Um...
it's like giving a baby up
for adoption.
And we writers try
really hard to...
to find a good home
for a baby.
But sometimes
it doesn't work out.
And, in my case, um,
you know, I was actually asked
to try and...
and interview Nick Cassavetes,
the director,
before he was hired.
And I said to him
that what was...
the only thing that was really
important to me in the book
that should stay
the same was the ending.
And I explained that,
it was what had sold,
all these copies of the book,
people going,
"I can't tell you
what happened, just read it,
so we can talk," you know.
And so he read the book,
and he said,
"you're right,
that's the only ending
for this story,
I'm not going to change it.
If anyone else does,
I'm going to tell you why and
I'm going to tell you myself."
And I thought, that's fair.
And he spent two years
writing a script,
he would call me weekly,
I would help him
whenever he asked,
with character, with dialogue,
with scenes, whatever.
And he would read me stuff.
And, um, then
at the end of that process,
a fan wrote me an email saying
they've gotten a script of
My Sister's Keeper
and did...
she worked
at a casting agency,
and did I know that they had
changed the ending.
So, I called Nick at home
and he wouldn't take my call.
I went to the movie set and
he threw me off the set.
I went to Newline Cinema
and I spoke to the head,
Toby Emmerich, and I said,
"You guys are going to
lose money on this film
because I have the best fans
in the world
and they are not going to be
happy with what you did."
And he said,
"No, no, you know,
we really trust Nick,
he did The Notebook for us,
he knows
what he is doing," and I said,
"okay" and I walked away.
And of course,
the movie was not successful.
It's a beautiful movie,
Nick filmed a beautiful movie
with wonderful
acting performances,
about dying with dignity.
That is not
what the book is about.
That's his interpretation,
but it's not what I thought
the book should be about.
And many of my
wonderful fans agreed
and the movie lost money.
And the really cool
silver lining here is that
ever since then, um...
I have had more clout
in Hollywood
because I apparently
am psychic and I told them
they were going to lose money.
( laughter )
So that's kind of cool.
But it was not a
pleasant experience.
Would it mean
that I wouldn't do it again?
No, because ultimately
let's be real
in most cases the book is
always better than the film,
right?
And for those of you, who went
to go see My Sister's Keeper
and were as disappointed
as I was,
the good news is that
you get to go home
and pull that
book off the shelf
and read the story
the way it should be. Right?
Yeah.
( applause )
Um, gentleman
in the blue shirt here.
Man: Hi, my wife and I are
both the oldest of four.
And I've had a lot of
discussions and hardship
with my relationship
with my mother,
because I was the one
who started...
- everyone leaving,
- Yeah.
So, you really said
that this was the core...
- Yeah.
- For the book.
How did this and this
journey of writing it
help you with
what you were going through?
That's a great question.
It really did help me.
Most of my books are
really my therapy session
for all of you to watch.
You know, it's something that
I'm really struggling with
and, and I wrestle it out and
throw it at other characters,
but really I'm talking about
something that's
upsetting to me.
And you know,
for me it really was that,
that sense, okay,
elephants and...
elephants, moms and daughters
they stay together forever,
so what does that
really mean for humans.
When people leave us,
do they ever really leave?
And I think that was really,
that was really the end point
that I came to.
Physical distance means
nothing.
That's details...
that when you love someone,
they are always with you.
- Right. So, we have a...
- This girl, we got a...
A wonderful woman
in the front.
- Yeah.
- In purple and black.
What kind of events
inspire you to write,
because, like in your book,
Nineteen Minutes ,
Peter Houghton goes on a
shooting rampage
in his school.
So, is it events like this
that inspire you to write?
I could write about any number
of really devastating topics
or things
that are very upsetting.
But I think
there's more to it than that.
I don't rip things
out of the headlines.
What I need to do
is to find something
that has intersected
in my life
at that moment in a way
that really moves me deeply.
And what moves me today,
might not be what moves me
in five years.
So, a book that I think,
"That's interesting
but not that interesting
right now,"
could completely change
five years from now.
I could be dying
to write that book.
So, there is this,
it's a dual feed,
part of it is,
things that I hear about,
things that I read about
in the world that...
that I have a curiosity about.
And the other part of it is
where I am in my own life.
It's funny, because,
I sometimes think,
you know very self-servingly
about 'Jodi Picoult 101',
which is going to be taught
clearly one day in college...
( laughter )
And, you know,
if you look at the trajectory
of my career,
my very first book was about
a mother and a daughter.
This book is about a mother
and a daughter again.
What's the difference?
When I wrote my first book,
I was closer in age
to the daughter.
Now, I'm closer in
age to the mother.
And in between I wrote about
the relationships between
men and women,
because I got married.
Then I wrote about
all the really scary things
that can happen
to your children,
because I had children.
It was like a whole run
of that for many years.
And now, you know, I'm moving
into more theoretical stuff,
the nature of good and evil,
you know, and...
and race for example,
things that are bigger,
because that's...
I have the luxury
of worrying about those things
and not just worrying
about my kids anymore.
I keep telling my mom
that one day I'm going to
write about putting your
parents in a nursing home.
( laughter )
She's really happy
to hear that.
( laughter )
Great. That's great.
Well, on behalf of all of us,
thank you so much for sharing.
Thank you.
Thanks for being here.
( applause )
( outro music )